it was so important to me that i wrote
it down and i have it right on front of
my computer
because it applies to almost everything
but especially to communication and
sales messages
what's going on everyone i wanted to
share the rule of one
with you that i learned from michael
masterson and if you haven't heard of
michael masterson he's uh
the the chief growth uh strategist at
agora publishing which
to my knowledge is the biggest
information seller on the market they do
over a billion dollars here in revenue
and he is the person who created their
entire acquisition machine which is
teams and teams of hundreds of
copywriters who
generate demand through compelling
words and i think there's something
really magical about that
because he not only has been able to do
it himself and hit home run after home
run out of a home run offer
but he's able to duplicate it in other
people and create and get people who've
never
sold a thing to writing copy that
generates 20 million 40 million 80
million plus just
from a single letter or message
and in his book great leads
the first concept that he introduces is
arguably the most important
and he calls it the rule of one and i've
been i
it was so important to me that i wrote
it down and i have it right on from my
computer
because it applies to almost everything
but especially to communication and
sales messages
and so whenever he said the common thing
that most copywriters do or most
business owners who are trying to
make an offer uh to be compelling to a
marketplace what they do
is they just stack as many different
great things inside as they possibly can
and then say well if that one doesn't
work one of them will work so i'm just
going to throw them all in
he said that's the recipe for he calls
toss salad copy
which is just you just jumble everything
together and you hope
you know it's throw everything on the
wall see what sticks but the reality is
the most compelling messages and he
reviewed the top 100 offers
of all times since they worked there uh
91 of them
all centered on a single concept and so
if you think about what that means it
means that
you're looking for the one big idea the
one compelling message
that has to be easy to understand easy
to believe
and interesting or unique and so he said
those are the three elements of a one
big idea and so when you're thinking
about the sales messaging and this has
been really just
i've been i've been putting this at the
forefront of my mind is that when you're
writing
copy for a uh for an advertisement or
you're writing copy for
a landing page the sub bullets should
only be bullets that
reinforce the singular message or the
singular argument
right they should be stories they should
be
arguments they should be facts that are
presented
solely to reinforce the singular concept
right
and so if i said you know hey there's uh
six ways
six ways to to to you know wake up
earlier or something like that
um or six morning strategies if each one
of them was kind of different
that's like it's it's a tossed salad
whereas if i wanted to center it around
one big benefit or one core topic
now the six topics that i could
underneath of it are gonna still be
sub points of the major one rather than
uh you know
15 crazy headline ideas right uh and so
for me that has been incredibly powerful
and if you look at
if if you have advertised before and you
look at the best converting
advertisements that you've ever had
you will probably see that similar trend
where the ones that do best
are the simplest the most direct and the
clearest to understand
now the issue is when you only have to
pick one it forces you to be incredibly
uh tactful on your selection because
you're only going to pick one and so i
think what that ends up doing is it
forces us as marketers
to really think is this the is this the
best idea
is this the most centralized focused
concept
that i can point as the tip of my spear
of my communication message right
and so a lot of these things around like
any kind of unique selling proposition
that's going to be the rule of one
right you don't want to have 19 selling
propositions you want to have one
core one that everyone can immediately
understand is is counter-intuitive
and uh is believable right and so when
you put all three of those things
together
then you have a message that's
compelling and people will take one step
towards you
and so um i have now like i said i wrote
that at the top of my computer and as
i've been writing copy
and keeping this a top of mind because i
can guarantee you that even since i
started doing this
just even reading the book i've gotten
the the copy that i've been putting out
has been so much better and more
targeted
and crisper because there's one central
idea i'm trying to
convince the reader or prospect of and
then and then the sales message that
follows is actually very transparent
and simple to write the hard part is
figuring out what that one idea is going
to be but if you're going to think about
one thing
then that would be the one to focus on
so anyways i hope that was valuable for
you i share this stuff as it comes to me
um in my in my journey of marketing and
sales
and so i hope you enjoy this like
subscribe all that kind of stuff and
i'll see you next video bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you